what's up mother people of the whole
entire world so we have these exclusive
topics that we want to talk about but
you know how the YouTube the
monetization and all that mother
[ __ ] be happening every time you
Steve talk about some conspiracies and
all that we want to go in deep we want
to get in depth with it
but we can't because every time you put
a little title of that says do you
monetize been [ __ ] buried so we
decided to put these kind of videos on
patreon here's snippets of what they
look like there's a taste today we're
gonna talk about the Flat Earth and why
it's a hundred percent real you believe
in that [ __ ] if the Sun is an order the
Moon or if you look either place their
orbs those are all black dude you might
not like how the way that I think I like
the way that you think the simulation
theory
so are we Holograms yeah you're thinking
Tupac at Coachella by the way take a DMT
hit right now [ __ ] just like Rick and
Morty but what do we use this time on
the porns just imagine you know there
could be like a bajillion different ways
where Julia can express herself yeah
Jeffrey Epstein we're talking about
facts after he was discovered running an
elite all right and you call your plane
to Lolita Express what is it with Keita
that makes these politicians so [ __ ]
horny the UFOs the lost city of Atlantis
see you wasn't that exciting that was
pretty exciting I am [ __ ] riveted joy
aside from keeping [ __ ] alive we want to
go deep into conspiracy corner time and
social justice league time and we have
all these different little formats that
are not safe enough for YouTube we will
be still releasing some on YouTube but
all the juicy stuff the juicy stuff you
got to go on patreon so make sure you
click on the link below in the
description box it'll take you straight
to the patreon and you can see all of
this mudda beauties go elbow deep with
us today yell Bodie in the rectums